[Music]
hi my name is elon scheif and today
we're talking hummus
my favorite is kind of like the classic
hummus with tahini which we're doing
today but my rule of thumb is everything
goes good on hummus
so the baking soda really begins to
break down the structure of the skins
that are on top of the garbanzo beans
when you soak them in it it starts to
break it down a little bit but then when
you drain it and bake it with a lot more
it really dries on there and really
starts to break down all that cell
structure of the skins and so now when
we go to rinse it those skins will just
kind of start to fall off kind of
massaging the beans to get the baking
soda off of it but also to get the skins
to start coming off and that's what's
going to really make it nice and tender
is as those skins fall off you get a
very smooth puree
[Music]
the hummus was one of the major major
things for us we made i think 80 batches
before we got it right where we wanted
it if we didn't get the hummus right we
wouldn't be standing here right now
you want them to be like falling apart
super mushy
when you sit down
in an arab restaurant in
israel
you typically get plates of hummus
and then you get plates of
moroccan carrot salad and pickled
cauliflower and tabouleh and baba
ganoush
and tahini
and like maybe some grated tomato and
extra virgin olive oil and a little sea
salt and like spicy peppers and then you
get all this pita and then that's kind
of the way your meal starts
and we were very particular to not cut
the bread like into little triangles or
whatever or
serve it you know with a knife we wanted
people to grab it
tear it open burn their fingers
and then like feel that kind of
connection you know where you're passing
somebody a piece of bread and then
you're grabbing a plate and then you're
sharing this and you're making bites for
people that's really kind of like the
beauty of
the food that we cook i think
[Music]
you